it doesn't matter how much you
understand something if you can't
communicate it in a simple and clear way
to others that's when ideas become
really powerful I had an unusual
entryway into mathematics it wasn't a
subject which I particularly enjoy when
I was the school but then when I arrived
at University intending to become a
teacher
there was one lecturer who came along he
said you know what we have this immense
need in mathematics and so it was his
words that sort of inspired me to say
well you know what there's an area of
need here I can do something to
influence young people for the future
and help them grow in that area so
that's what set me in this path I think
stories at the heart of how every human
being communicates anything really and
that especially includes really
challenging you know profound difficult
concepts like mathematics when I thought
about how I wanna explain mathematics to
people I thought I wonder if they can
actually embrace it as a story you want
children to be able to sense oh this is
actually something I can wrap my head
around and that I can enjoy and once
they realize wow this is something I can
enjoy it's worth putting effort into
[Music]
about five years ago I had a student of
mine who was diagnosed with cancer
standard policy would be to say okay
we'll look he's a textbook go and do
chapter 5 work on that we'll see you in
a month when you return to school but
most people can't understand mathematics
like that
[Music]
all I did was got my phone out of my
pocket put it in the middle of my
classroom mount it up on top of a chair
and I hit record and that's where it
began
[Music]
without me expecting you people from
around the school other schools and then
it just sort of grew across the country
and even now the world started watching
along and you know its success is just
as much a surprise to me as anyone else
I've been teaching and recording for
almost five years now and every time I
think about a concept that I've
explained before I think I can do it a
different way I wonder if this might be
better and I think it's that that drive
to improve and to make things connect
with a wider range of people or in a
deeper way than it ever has before I
think that's what makes me constantly
get better as a community